georges-emmanuel clancier avait déjà
publié beaucoup de livres auparavant des
poèmes des essais d'autres romans dont
un gros roman s'appelle un noir et on
avait l'impression qu'il avait déjà peu
près tout me levais essentielle de sa
pensée de son coeur dans son oeuvre et
puis ce livre alors fait penser qu'au
contraire il réservé jusqu'à présent ce
qui était le plus près de lui ce que ce
qu'ils voulaient préserver pour plus
tard et c'est ce gros livre
georges-emmanuel clancier à ce livre
vous l'avais appelé l'éternité pour un
plus un jour c'est un très beau titre
c'est un titre symbolique c'est le thème
de votre livre oui c'est un titre
symbolique mais c'est aussi qu'ils aient
choisi ce titre parce que comme il vous
plaira soutien par sa féerie et par sa
magie toute la première partie de louis
puisque aussi bien vous savez que ce
sont des jeunes des groupes de jeunes
vers les années 34,36 qui répètent comme
il vous plaira et qui jouent cette pièce
de shakespeare et c'est pourquoi je vous
rencontre sur une scène les le thème en
effet deux titres l'état n'était plus un
jour m'a semblé être le thème central de
ce livre qui par ailleurs a peut-être
beaucoup de chemins divers et multiples
il m'a semblé que que chaque homme porte
en lui ce besoin d'état n'était plus un
jour pour accomplir tout ce qu'il
voudrait accomplir que ce soit un amour
comme c'est le cas pour orlando et
rosalen et pour les héros du centre du
livre et une amitié une action une
oeuvre et même une vie une vie d'enfant
est toujours trop courtes pour toutes
les promesses qu'elle semblerait
contenir au départ et qui ne trouveront
jamais si vous voulez leur
accomplissement total c'est une
inspiration pathétique en somme
oui et par exemple j'ai trouvé d'autres
images qui viennent peut-être illustrer
ce que vous dites et et reprendre ce
thème de l'état n'était plus un jour il
ya beaucoup de thèmes votre mur oui il y
à il ya tous les thèmes de la vie la vie
est faite de thèmes
j'ai voulu composer ce livre un peu
comme serait un musicien avec des thèmes
musicaux plus qu'avec des thèses en
trouver là
très loin des thèses est une roche en
effet du thème au sens musical du terme
et c'est ainsi que une autre image pour
moi de l'état n'était plus un jour c'est
celle d'un couple de gisants que j'ai
toujours regardé avec beaucoup de
d'amitié de tendresse à l'image ma ville
natale et même encore lorsque chaque
fois que je vais là-bas que je reviens
là bas je ne manque pas d'aller rendre
visite à ce couple de deux jeunes époux
du moyen-âge mais gisant en ai-je parlé
à esther nom à elle n'y a personne
jamais et pourtant au déclin du jour
lorsque le jardin derrière l'abbatiale
de saint georges des lions et des airs
tant et tant de fois je suis venu comme
un rendez vous donné par delà les
siècles me recueillir devant un jeune
couple
à vrai dire cela a été difficile la
préparation de livres pour arriver à
cette apparente peut-être simplicité qui
est celle de la vie pendant des années
de 1960 à 1964 j'ai accumulé des notes
qui étaient des notes de préparation des
notes de travail des portraits de
personnages des réflexions des souvenirs
des lieux également mais j'étais hanté
habité par mes histoires mais je
n'arrivais pas à nouer et à faire vivre
ensemble tous ces personnages allaient
groupés autour de lieux et autour de
l'hymne centrale jusqu'au jour où j'ai
eu envie d'évoquer par des mots et des
images une vieille maison romantique un
observatoire romantique qui dans ma
ville natale et maisons qui m'a toujours
fasciné et du jour d'avril 64 j'ai eu
l'idée de faire cela d'écrire une page
sur cette maison
tout a démarré c'est à dire que certains
personnels se sont mis à vivre dans
l'observatoire d'autres qui sont henri
veyrier le narrateur et sa famille se
sont placés dans la maison d'en face est
dorénavant j'avais le pivot central et
la vie s'est organisée comme dans la vie
même au tour cet observatoire
[Musique]